el calcinado mercado de barbas job a una
iglesia ortodoxa rusa el hospital de al
lado incluso un centro juvenil de
deportes y apartamentos todo esto ha
sido alcanzado por las bombas nos vamos
a entrar en santis acá en este barrio
de medio millón de personas a la mayoría
sea
que quedar sobreviven como pueden
cerca de salt iscar este barrio el
dormitorio al noroeste dejar que
disparan el ejército ruso y ucraniano es
difícil encontrar a personas paseando
por la calle porque es peligroso estar
aquí están a poca distancia de los
misiles línea y anatoli son de los pocos
que aceptan hablar
mills attack
es increíble lo que le están haciendo al
pueblo ucraniano
nos han asediado la gente vive en la
pobreza creo que los saqueos comenzarán
pronto la gente tiene hambre frío no
tiene ropa
un metro a mí me gusta más tratamos el
señor batería de repente línea sale
corriendo se va sin exclusiones
saliendo y gane
lina está asustada
ha sido un gran susto la contraofensiva
ucraniana para parar a las tropas rusas
en este frente del norte retumba en este
barrio devastado donde ni siquiera llega
la ayuda humanitaria